- So there was one night
at the comedy club,
um they gave out Nerf balls,
and I was a cocktail
waitress at a comedy club.
So, gotta be honest with you,
never handed out Nerf balls.
What's happening here?
- So, I was doing a, I was,
I wasn't even going up.
I just went to go watch an
open mic with my friend,
and he signed me up and they called
"Miss Pat coming to the stage."
And I'm like, "I am"?
And so at this night, it was a black spot.
They throw balls, Nerf balls
at you if you don't like 'em,
if they don't like you-
- What?
- And the guy hit me in my forehead,
I didn't even get the joke out so-
(laughs)
Y'all I'm an ex drug dealer
and I'm ready to fight.
So, I-
- Wait! Wait!
(laughs)
You left that out in your
10 second spiel, okay.
- Oh yeah. I trafficked a lot of cocaine
back in the nineties.
(audience laughs)
(clapping)
- My God.
- Oh yeah, honey.
- Oh my God.
- Hey, I'm like, I like Narcos.
- Oh my God! You're right.
Your ten second story
wouldn't have held out.
- No but I, I do think we
should talk afterwards.
(laughs)
(clapping)
- I'm a Christian now
I eat at Chick-fil-A.
- I eat at Chick-fil-A (laughs)
- That's one of those,
that's one of those things
that I'm not sure if it means something,
but it means something.
- I don't go to church,
but I eat Christian chicken.
- Christian chicken.
It's, we called it bedside Baptist.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- That's what we called
it, bedside Baptist.
- After he hit me with the
Nerf ball and I'm so I, I mean
I come from a bad relationship
a crazy background
and I just scream,
"Everybody, let's rob him!"
And they was like, "you at a comedy club."
(laughing)
- I love that that's your reaction.
- That was my reaction.
And I got a standing ovation.
- [Man] That's great.
(audience laughs and claps)
That's a good way to deal with hecklers.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah, I
was gonna say, turn it around.